the story of dennis molz it is
quite outstanding
because he has probably managed to build at least one unicorn in the most capital-
efficient way of all
in recent years
, which means that with
only five million so only in the sense of
only five million to just one
billion  building up the company that
is not that old then usually
needed a lot more money to take on
investors but then it's just not and
how he managed it why he chose the
segmented mattresses in the first place
and why it was also possible with mattress panes
and how it was  in the end
it was possible he really told me
an amazing story how
do you get mattresses for a
multi-billion company many
assumptions made it dennis Schmelz she made
it after many, many years
it's about sleeping again for us and
now maybe with the market leader who's
after  many years of fierce
competition in the mattress market
seems to have prevailed at least
you're just talking about
emma is always the song company and the
founder's name is denis melted and
modern
has been there is still so
relatively had magna is is a
highly competitive market absolutely that that
's correct but how development
so i inherited my intro she referred
to casper there i had
a podcast many years ago you so
yes it is also one is your market
accompany company not whether there
is or was there a whole
series of funds that were mattresses
so that americans are also the most well-known
you are also very timely applies exactly
we actually
started at a similar time so once there have been six years since the end of
2015 that was also the
time when football started and
many others started too but
football will be back at some point  and
europe went out while we
continued to grow diligently here so yeah
that was inspir back then  t
there were many
startups that were not described that were
on the move in this area and in this
respect one naturally comes to terms with differences in the
business model one has to
say it wasn’t the first thing that many
thought again and again but of course
one looked across the pond and has  also
good what actually happens
there but we were already on the road before
when a business model we
originally had mattresses of all
different types and brands online
offer when you actually
originally online shop for mattresses
and only then in 2015, so to speak,
switched two years two and a half years
earlier along the  way and
then focused on our own products, own
brand, so it was a
process with us and before that you were a
few years because we know you in the
advice center or should I have
done it before that means somehow a
classic somehow tried and tested then
with  located across from chiemsee okay what
makes you start it came up despite the
topic yeah that's not like
classic basic think about storage
where is there still portrait level you can
earn money with us it was different
so just said that yes founder but
one of the two founders together
with  marie müller and you had
something to do with medical mattresses
and
saw well that there are
medical mattresses market he is
relatively difficult and had seen
that there is an opportunity to
simply sell mattresses to the end
consumer and
i was us  I've been friends for a long time. I
was with a management consultancy
and you can
definitely build business models there. Scrub excel sheets and
draw powerpoint. In this respect,
I had an opinion whether I wanted to help and
we should look at it together at the time,
whether you weren't in this mattress market
or broadly  sleep market not
what can do and that's how we came to
it or i  ch came to it
so the start was not so much
excel like what kind of opportunities gypsum
and which finished ones do we go for
now that wasn’t our question ok
but if you look at the business model
so selling mattresses or
producing mattresses yourself
actually appears  I also
thought about it back then somehow
it's not the most lucrative thing in the world
at first it's not new it's
also not that much technology at first
you have somehow relatively
bad re-purchase rates you should
think you bought the mattress but not the
next  week the next or so and
if with crm you can't
somehow motivate the customer again
so many things that i
thought ok
why is a very attractive why he
then you know expert said
ok bet on that i'll go there now
and  I'm a bit of a risk.
It also took a while before I was
convinced  but hello we
're about to start our first online shop
and now we're going to have a look at how
the first sales have
developed before I'll go tactically as I said
but it's an exciting
market it's an exciting market because
it was so well established  our goal
isn't just to somehow
develop the next product,
our goal is really to
improve sleep and if you
think about it,
innovations in this area are almost
non-existent, which is
why our suggestion that we've also created
upsets by now building
mattresses  the
test winners keep coming, so all
over europe we have a lot of test wins for our
product alone, which other companies,
some of which have been in industry for almost a
century, have not yet been able to
achieve and we also go one
step further, i.e. what
we are currently developing and have
developed too  already
have a mattress on the market  e which is
smarter so why should the passive
fit be a passive product if you
can only lie on it why does
n't the product actively adapt to someone
so if i turn from left to right at night
then more can
happen and that developed for me
i.e. a smart mattress that adapts to
the body and with this in
mind we are thinking about sleep innovations
and we have a team of
30 people based here in frankfurt to
promote exactly this it is a
totally exciting area so no
politics or a mattress is ours
our core product today bread and
butter business are
actually mattresses but we see ourselves as a
hit company that's why this
subtitle the song company we say
we want to improve sleep and
we think very broadly about
what that means and work on
new products
and i think so  it is also that also
deserves sleep so just so to speak all
listeners that time  to make it clear if we
sleep not only a third of our
life, i.e. eight hours at a time,
you should in any case, for all those who have
a bit of a sleep deficit here,
he has it is also just enormously
important for the immune system, for learning,
even for emotional health,
it’s enormous  important to sleep well because
it has been found that research
that well dreaming helps
to process emotional moments better so
that's why sleep is super important and
that's why it's just a nice task
I want to improve my sleep with which I'm very
infected films
actually sells that  i do
n't know exactly but are millions
yes they are ok that means for me to the
next question you do you know a
podcast you i
'm trying to add a little bit to sales yes what are
you doing there last year we turned over 645
millions
ok that  is already on the outside there
aren't that many companies on the
inside we are now  six years old
within six years
something like 100 million what's
more yes we have grown by 60 percent
from 400 405 million to now 6 145
million last year we now have the
latest figures almost 900 people in
our company  to berlin no we are based in
frankfurt and we are not only based in
frankfurt now also in lisbon in
mexico in the philippines and in
shanghai 75 office is now
very international you are
on the road in 30 countries
and that’s why we
are now on the road all over the world  and are you
selling now hold on trading
i think i can read in the preparation
so you also sell to the
famous mattresses concord but he
embodies david here you can
just do both exactly we originally came
from the online retail sector
as just described that
means  it's our german consumer
business that we originally
started with abe  r we'll see each other
now sony player so we're in
i think over 3,500 stores worldwide
now with several hundred
retail partners so it's
really grown quite a bit
and i'm always happy to say yes
just that that that you that you like
it  maybe it's also surprising
we're another
underdog of the german startup scene
the biggest investors we
've collected another five million euros
and to be honest we were certainly
not the best at raising capital
so at the beginning we
would certainly have liked to have raised more  but
we didn't make it, we
probably lacked some skills,
maybe to tell a big story the other
way around, to lose we were
also more risk it would be if i'm
very risk-averse insofar as your always made
very down-to-earth plans
, but then they always fulfilled
so and so  That's very capital efficient,
so out of five million  en
make of 650 and probably a
company value how is that something that we like
trade kaspar are currently implementing yes i
think caspar has just developed a
bit differently maybe
you haven’t followed that anymore
kasper has now gone from the
stock exchange were sold  for about
300 a bit, i think 300
million,
so everyone can do their own
calculations, of course, you can look at the
competitors, the stock exchanges are
listed and malt apple users
are, for example, one of the
world's largest is tempo
, they're called they're now
mark has been thinking about it for a very long time is not a start-up
orange you can't see what you have
that you know exactly now you
bought it yourself so from two to three it
's not that high never will be
somewhere between 1 and 2
let's take 12  take a look at your good
growth care is at 2 then you will be
de facto unique was that is your
bill
[yelp  hter]
june communists and are looking for and
it has never appeared up to now we
are more like the underdogs because we also
do good business we
are growing becoming good because i mean
when the growth figures attack
you tag i only then really often
unfortunately i didn't meet him personally as a regular guest
but he builds
you i think has grown in these first six
years as always in the
first six years so i think
your stock where 700 so many millions
260 45 millions ended last year
so if that's one  very similar
how do you do that's probably the dogs yes
how that is what's there what's there
what there the mattresses others sell
so now not that you say he
's somehow vaccinated or something
like that I think it's about that
you definitely have a good product but
what we particularly believe in is why a
company like this is more successful than
many competitors than all of them  competitor
is the way we approach things
so i think in the end
it is execution not so much how much money
you have or something like that if so much then
sometimes a bit almost scared
so my main main view of
entrepreneurship is not something per se
building big things i think is
exciting and entrepreneurial when
you build something big with limited
resources and from ah i sometimes
find it how it is in the startup scene is the
definition of how big is a
funding round and how many people
you have was so limited helpful
actually the most exciting company
that doesn't actually need money and
maybe doesn't even need people
and for that and because it's
going to be big so i have a slightly different
definition
i think entrepreneurs do i think that's
about the costs accordingly so how  can you get it
out i think we are a very
complementary is no longer in the trade
with green and i  ch yes but then it's
also about how we recruit how
we did the campaign as a violation campaign
design spend most of
my time dealing with such topics with
people york topics
how do we build the sensation that it
keeps this entrepreneurial spirit even if
we now have 900 people  so are things like
not having any bonuses can't have the
budgets no ball process through cold
apartment where do you live mostly what
became people employees collectibles
however is totally great and then
people walk a bit faster
i think that they are very short-sighted
shows  but also researchers i think
there is a really great ted talk by the
pink wahlers who
talks about the fact that research is common
sense that bonuses do not help but they are
still used everywhere to this day
but you have topics such as the bonus
you can you in a  complex
situations such as a company not
perfectly define that means above
all one  agile environment it is
the target definition but
within weeks it is
no longer the right one and has to
change that get rid of that has to talk to the employee
explains to her that there is
now another bonus
definition and that is
comparable to what he says
could and should have achieved previously so
that kind of idle discussion
then you suddenly have people who have
their own agenda and that leads to
company politics it leads to elbowing it
doesn’t lead to people saying okay
what can we do best together here
in the  company is like that when
we find out that he can somehow do one
area crm is not going so well
we need capacities in the other
area then i simply move the people
around then we create the capacities
or if we find that one country is
growing faster than the other  both
need software
development capacity he then
we just collect around then will
not discussed for long because everyone
understands that makes sense for the company
and you won't get it if god
with them let's say design themes or
do you call it organizational airline
themes
in his market really get so much
differentiation or so many
advantages so that you can now
oppose  there are really plenty of
mattresses racial or this year it
was really the this the suite
walked through the golf course exactly how you
react that the reaction we had
repeatedly received from investors in the
past that's
why i felt so bad about collecting
money because there  told me it
can't be, but that's the way it is, i
think when you come to see us in
frankfurt, of course, the seat is definitely
a bit different, but if you just experience
this beehive, so to speak
, you realize that the
environment is very entrepreneurial  in 2020 we got
haniel on board as an investor as a partner
and part of the reason they
invested was because they want to use that
DNA we have the situation designers
approach for the
transformation years other
business models they have so that's
why
the way we approach recruiting is
n't experience based it's
personality based  like us
some people today that
is the startup story at the beginning the
tool country manager you will have
little experience with no idea but until today it
is the case that people who are interns
or straight from the university then come to
us within a year
responsible for domestic like switzerland or austria
so far away i liked to say people who
start with us and maybe
also see us as a company
stepping stone within two
years because sometimes two million
sales start to build up were our
campaign the holidays because you can do the social
in  can create this environment but
still had to di  e customers have to
go to the market like the brand
there isn't one so you
have to look there that's all if they then
search on google people on
mattresses and max are particularly clever that
's one finds you or you have it there
also found some other communication
points to half yes accelerate that so
much i think that what we can
do very well it then
excellence and in that respect a question
maybe to be answered a bit further of
course it's not
just the organization but it
's what the organization is  in the end it makes
and that's how we managed to
build up an andi team that can achieve test winners
, but we've also built up a
marketing team is simply the
most efficient online marketing
from what we at least see in
this highly competitive market and
that's why we're in the market ourselves
we got to the uk late compared
to our competitors so we had
two competitions  rber who started in the uk got a
lot of funding after that we started
at night after two
years or so we started there in the uk
and thought we would
always be a little bit the smaller
player but that's not the
case we are  now the largest in the
uk because we do online marketing better
than and online what is
your performance marketing of the features
marketing so absolutely google google
adwords facebook instagram
and tv are the
main channels and you
can always get this quality better known there  and
even now it's not quite new anymore,
but you can still
differentiate yourself by quality that you
can feel better that was worse at times
it's the way you do it
offers on keywords the keywords and
also known the prices are like all
of us  based on the conversion needs a
strong side where can you
do something if today it would still be a target for
against that but today  i say
difficult but i think alone if you
think about tv how do i measure the tv
how do i track that because it is not an
online channel the money will come back to
my website how can i
identify them then that they come from the tv
they are not like that  very simple
question and if you then see the whole thing
more complex with ok then go
which times via google then it went
over again i don't know came
across a recommendation from a
customer how do i build it into an entire
action model so there that is that it
that  I don't think it's such an
easy task where I think
other companies are also working
intensively on it, so big
companies and I think if you
find a
better approach to it that you
definitely get performance out of it, but you're
not the types who are in that now  with
let's say incredibly aggressive
creatives or any action
reacting makes it rather conservative good
the description  bt very good so
I have to admit I don't think we
understood the brand for years so
we are yes there are many start ups
looks ok according to it we have to
build up the brand first we didn't really understand the brand for a long time
and
something just
worked for us and  let's
be the brand it works that way it's
more performance-driven
that has of course changed in the meantime
because of course we
also understand the value of a brand
meanwhile i had to learn
but it was the first time
optimizing the performance of the company
merkel understand what's doing now  for the
brand so what is so what
we started was always in
word i don't even know what kind of
undefinable font in a
definable and blue gray green
came about so nobody did
so i somehow cobbled it together during the night and
foggy actions
yes, in the meantime it is clear to us what
positioned that's again making
your base it's about that you can
simply sleep a better life first be
a better yourself so
and to play that and also to
differentiate yourself emotionally that's what
we what we have understood in the meantime
what we can also do  play our tv spots like
the game on the website
again, which you then play consistently
and that of course has
added value i think but that you
should deal with it if you already have
customers i often have the feeling that the
start-up deals with it very early on
deal with it too early deal with it
then also waste money
meanwhile the agency does that but he
has the brands himself we do
a lot ourselves we support ourselves
selectively then when we realize
that we sometimes don't have the capacity or the creative
capacity built in
i mean  there is that is
always enriched, so to speak,
externally again look at it  n to
leave this this this last work
we did there we also
had external support yes
reference to a regular partner
here in the podcast and all sorts of kl a
die ko aleix a young company
trying to close the gap
between what e  commerce shops and dealers can
currently afford and what
buyers often expect it is often
about having the right track for
the customer pro active shipping
communication track and trace a
digital amri tour portal all of this is
simply what customers expect many companies
can't afford it then  does
it just aleikum they make
sure that you make your fulfillment as a
dealer much easier if
you hand it over to a co and you can
escalate infinitely a very simple
control of the al-ko platform colleague
paul ripke told a few weeks ago in the
podcast from rajko  he also uses
it for his grand prix just like
many others use it  si companies
also make chocolate, among other things, no wonder that
at mr reviews, the ratings of all
users are far above the
industry average, so the stars that are distributed
there do not have to be significantly higher
who wants to know more everywhere aiko all
information on the landing page reiko dot
com
mr
and  the mattresses themselves so the product
plays a big role for you there
are also these approaches that
I think I forget you've
learned from what you buy from you can still
exchange them free of charge for the first
90 days I think you don't either
it means you need a good product
otherwise you get it back or
maybe it hasn't been returned
yet but it can still be back so
we have to ask but i put a lot of
effort into who made it so is it made
in germany or where exactly i
so we all shouted here we
are now traveling around the world as
long as we have a lot of
production partners  he so our approach is
that we still cover the mattresses or the products as
a whole beds pillows
under the smart mattress we
all build or we develop everything ourselves in
terms of design how does it have to be
expanded so that it is economical so it is
durable etc
have production partners  for the
30 we now also
have european mattresses from around the world, but
the mattresses for
latin america come from latin america,
some of the mattresses are even
exported to asia and the pacific, i.e.
to australia, among other places
, even mattresses from from
europe, so a lot  a lot can be found here in
many european city white also just
makes sense so you it's a
big product but it's not 1 1
should i say it's also a lot
it's not no asylum not like an
iphone together where such a small
product is called  what is simply worth a lot
in the mattress is simply very
bulky
products starts at  was a little over 200 euros and
then there really is our
smart mattress in the sales not in
germany but it costs a few thousand
euros vehicle
we have there our strategy was
how to proceed i think such a smart
product had to be presented through
trading partners between switzerland
buy us something expensive
online, so that's why we're currently
on the road with the smart mattress in switzerland
, but we have our
roadmap, how we roll it out and because
it's so often smart system in the
foam who somehow
know that it's digital  because
that's more important as a product in the sense
of post a sensor mat inside that
detects and recognizes through artificial
intelligence like sea bream so
the opposition detection lies on it and can then
adjust the shoulder zone and the hip
because if you lie on your side
you have to  relieve your shoulders more when you are
on the way back your shoulders must be tightened
back is supported and
that makes the mattress active it
adjusts itself next to it 40 50 80 times a
night depending on how it is not back
and forth and that you
connect the electricity is connected to the electricity
exactly aha of course you know practiced
and patents hope  the fact that we have one
of the actuators that means the
mechanical participation in the forest has been
patented
and so why did the money tell
you now the majority, i think
50.1 percent of haniel that is then
native ruhr area people says what it is
so is the industrial dynasty the path so
what was it now not so
super likely without but what was nice is
we sat with thomas so it was difficult with
the cio from haniel at the beginning of 2020 it
was determined that we
tick very similarly so that was yes
a little teaser beforehand
was jones -- who, like us, run
a company like this and is entrepreneurial
and realized that we
e  just think in a similar way and that this can become a
good partnership because of
course haniel is also very financially strong
, so when there are opportunities
you always have a good, strong partner
at your side, and that’s how it turned
out, especially since we had a lot of
small investors there  we had
really made termin friends rounds
so i think we had a cartel of 50
people and they simply
consolidated it and that's how it
came about and i did
n't make a capital increase either then
i would just buy applications exactly that were
n't a capital increase  he only sells shares
because he probably
wanted for you two years ago he
goes big doesn't replace the size
now but then it was probably
i would have always put in has been very worthwhile the
last few years
our business is worth it
overall but
there is also  have a connection to the
group that this manager is d  as
not an investor i described it earlier
so yes it first
of all an investor for us in the sense of or the partner
i would even say because we don't
need an investment per se partner for us
with whom he works and where i
actually get involved again and again
I'm in this
transformation that I described
earlier, so we're currently discussing how
you can bring certain approaches
into this new, this entrepreneurial
thinking in other
portfolio companies,
so I'm part of the ceo community, so to speak, and I'm
trying to
support that, okay  and the whole
business would be you can only make
such sales so the
secondary there will be no
capital increase in the end that everything
can grow from the cash flow that means
yes you have also managed that
the cash flow is profitable or a lot
generate and if so
we've been running profitable for a
few years now and  with significant
investments, of course, you also have to
invest in
china, which is certainly not the
easiest market, or the usa are
now also present, that meanwhile, markets
that also require a bit of
perseverance and to provide lesbians, the margin on your
mattress is
quite good,
the margin  on the mattress is so that
we also have a business model
i mean to be fair also all
the retailers who are active in this area
around all the competitors we
also have a business model so from
that point of view it is not surprising that
you can work with mattresses with peace
products that you need can also
earn money so anything else would be
absurd but that means it has to be a
good time because the repeat purchases
can't be or they can
be repeat purchases you typically have
a period of 10 years of course what
you try what everyone is trying to do  is of
course about products like pillow
covers and co. also chew again
f but in principle
it is of course clear that we can
get there as described so we
have to see that we pay our marketing
from it we see that we
pay our people from it but that
absolutely 15 and we have been surprised up to now
the business model is with
where you earn money i don't
want that no i said to myself this is now
in the start-up scene one of the
models that i didn't expect
that i can understand that there are
discussions about e-commerce so it
came up or many things that were
just so logical  appears when the
networks came on social
networks okay it's trying to build your network
so it was clear to me that
you can do it is that somehow has a great
mission and so with mattresses it's
at first glance it's a very
old business why  and of course
I've always been strong how can it be done differently if I understand that
but I think so  be so far away is just
like it was before and
you have to get excellence along the entire supply chain
and that's what makes the
difference there are also a lot of us
competitors if we talked about
some other big us
caspers who have difficulties
with  the profitability they don't get the
profitability there at least
not sustainably and in that respect it's
difficult for me to take time out
to talk about the competitors
and i think that we're doing the right thing
is that we're
trying to create excellence along all points so i
think we're real  excellent at
how we build mattresses how we have them
produced i really hope
we have the best in the world all the
team for consumer mattresses we are
excellent at how we do the
marketing so we don't use any
agencies between us because they can't teach us
anything not on that  we just do it
much better in the house hi  we get to see
that the whole topic of recruiting is
concerned we have a team of about
30 people in recruiting because we
conduct 40 interviews every week
to cover our recruiting needs because
we know exactly who we need
how much what percentage of their turnover
is approximately  marketing
yes, we don't publish exact
figures, but that's already a double-digit
percentage, smaller than a double-digit
percentage, okay, so we're talking
something between 60 and 100 million
marketing a year has already shot up, that
will probably be the direction
and the proportion of smaller products
than pillow covers will cover that  also in that
area so from the whole thing we looked at
what we also
discover we have new pillows blankets
beds are a particular topic at the moment
and of course our mattresses
just as suddenly not so
much on our mind but we look
at the company management so try that
probably the countries grow as well as
sozus  agen the individual categories are
progressing
and so there are then, so to speak
, focus focus topics again and if you look
now so pursuers are the
market from the corner of your eye somehow
also concludes something
meanwhile nevertheless companies are sponsoring
tennis tournaments the spots sponsoring a
so it was something  you do or is too
far away he is sports sponsoring of
course even if the
requests keep coming up but so far we
haven't dared to go there because and
we dare to go back to the topic
we have difficulties measuring
that so we who we still know  not
exactly how we would deal with it
as long as we don't know that you
'd rather keep your fingers off of the
whole modern influenza look
at to the present but not
sales of a reasonable size so here
now even ok have hundreds of thousands of fans
or even years all over Gaul  acquired
but is not a tempting count think
30 50,000 euros but that's au  ch again
such a very interesting example of how
household busy whether in whether instagram
our organic account whether it
actually drives performance and what
many have at least understood and
think they have recognized that it doesn't
do that much insofar as I know that
some startups also believe them
we should have
a lot of followers on facebook and on overall and
crew supancic and have now
tried something for a while
but just didn't get any performance
out of it why should I do it
then so the water over most of them is still
seeing that people use these channels
if you have customer service inquiries
actually so he had to put a
customer service team there as a community
manager very expensive as it helps yeah yes
tell me but really likes to have fans
sure that the great testimonials
or great big house for you like
posts are human material always existed
slept totally well somehow comes on
sand then so we h  But also in Brazil, for example
,
I'm not happy who's that like never before,
but in Brazil, for example, we've
tried out bigger influenza now, we're testing
things and there are countries where it works well, and there are countries
where it doesn't work so well
so without knowing that exactly now
i want to assume that it will be
very difficult in the usa because
the prices for influenza
marketing are probably so expensive chance that you
can no longer get infected with it and
even now the
market entries are like this again in china and the usa
yes huge so that one
trusts the usa alone as a german company is
no longer quite normal these days very
few trust these two
countries what are you doing so optimistically
yes what makes us optimistic is that
we keep learning to try things out with our approach
and don't burn a lot of money
have
always made good progress in the past
but didn't notice the a  That
's definitely the case, but we're
now in all the top 10 largest
mattress markets in the world or sleep
markets in the world, and that includes
the USA and China, so it was
clear to us that we wanted to  so our aspiration
is to become the biggest punch brand in the
world then
we have to tackle these countries too and we have now worked with
about 30 countries, so to speak, europe
we are now successfully
on the road
in latin america mexico china colombia brazil in asia pacific i.e.
with australia japan
the philippines and how does he do that
is always the animal then opens an office
or do you just do it from
frankfurt that we then simply
pull up sour landing pages and shops and the
simple version that asks itself tax
or does our blue really go the
market
that's how  you never wrote
from frankfurt or originally from
frankfurt meanwhile we have w  more
offices but the suggestion or our
consideration was well to start in a country
and find out if it
works i don't have to
open an office how expensive and needs advance notice
and then deal with it a lot
and maybe even
rely on the entire supply chain for what we do  he once sent over
a container of mattresses and
sold it to see if it
works and if i see that it
works then i
can continue to push the accession to power
okay okay and then there is
another special market, such as
china  it would have been clear to us that
we on site we now need
a team of 30 people in shanghai
who are now pushing the chinese city
forward and we also see
other countries like south korea or
japan and india these are countries where
we are aware  we probably need
to have a local presence in japan
, that's already the case in south korea and
i  not yet so insofar as
almost one of your listeners is keen on
source he should be happy to
contact you as otto pöhl in residence he is then
welcome to apply that i would be happy to apply to me
personally
[laughter]
based on experience nevertheless this the
chick model what also  the big topic
was founding startups and then selling directly
to the end customer, bypassing the trade, did that work out
afterwards
or did it not
work out after all, he has
meanwhile gone through the trade a lot, if
i read it like that, it worked for us
that the chick models and online model are
very, very good there we continue to grow
enormously fast again
compared to certain US competitors, for example, who can
no longer manage online growth themselves,
but
what we simply see is when we are
the largest city  wanting to be the brand of the world
whatever it is it's just the
customer and there are enough customers is a
huge segment that  would like to experience the product
before you buy it
, so we are very happy about
the partnerships we have with our
hotel partners  okay i
assume right in pattaya ried ellison
is a is a different business so of
course they have a much
larger order but of course that
is more selective then not continuous
but lets if you would i work with
this logic that you run your own
warehousing then then  are the
biggest change, but they are
spread over many weeks, so to speak,
or that is then sold off,
insofar as retail is simply another
part of our véronique kanel strategy,
so I think it makes sense
to process it accordingly,
because customers are as described  they can
see us online
when in doubt  get and see each other again on
tv
a recommendation from the customer say yes
i want to experience it before
i buy it why shouldn’t i
give it to you and work accordingly
with 3500 stationary
stores otherwise already together if now
the situation
expansion then always does things
through retail or through disney
so we start almost everywhere you have to
consider whether there are exceptions almost
everywhere
online first because that means
we can make extremely good decisions especially since how
does it share when he's there  need
people on site, so a retail partner
would of course also
like to have the appropriate support somehow would
like to have a local contact
person who might come
by if there is a topic,
so you have to
create appropriate structures, but we have that
for example right now  done now the
last year in uk built up our
team and france in span  ien
so because the teams the teams are also growing
and that was my article reading the
business week about you that
even interns
are allowed to conclude contracts over 10,000 euros that's the way it is
yes I said before
we don't have no budget with us
no processes that all me this logic
that the company is
designed we are someone coming in the of
course there was my case already
no question but the point
is that the fa cups are smaller the
smaller problem compared to
that you lose the entrepreneurship
because if you don't call up processes if
the intern always
has to run someone else first you have to
say can I do that now that takes
longer and the other thing is well you think
then
someone else
has to do really good work on the cote de as justified  I don't do that, he
will have the more knowledge he will
decide when I make myself
responsible for your for 10  ,000 euros
then I want to do a
damn good job as an intern and
think twice about it again
, does it really matter now, so it really is, I
think these processes have budgets,
that's all this risk management
that big companies do because they're afraid
of  have errors but I think you
have to keep this DNA
so that I have to keep it
than because many
start-ups also have this risk.
Let it be tested. Let it be
tested
averse now everything has to be
checked and now there are
decision templates
so everything is rippling for me you only
slowly become less
entrepreneurial i think it’s really
bad
sorry that i’ve
only just finished the preliminary talks that gave the
example of how you
got rid of the process, so to speak  acts and also somehow
acts without budgets that that that
ryanair lufthansa example yes he
likes  clarify so the logic is that we don't
want any processes to get people involved in maintenance
and an example is
with very simple things like the travel
policy when you say people
can we fly 200 euros 200 euros and you
have a flight that on the one hand is from
ryanair or from  lufthansa at the same
time in the ryanair flight costs 30
euros the lufthansa flight 190 euros yes what
do you need if the travel policy
allows the 200
euros of losses the lufthansa flight if you do
n’t have this policy or just say
you should be smart in the interest
deal with the company then you will see significantly more
people, namely almost everyone who
honestly tells us yes the ryanair flight
is exactly the same costs 30 euros
we take that
and but it is one of the drivers you
have from magath you have to be the test winner
is the test winner  its
probably the most important seal
in business in general
so it's a bit like that too you were
test winners is there  nn everything works if you
're not then everything helps
google optimized and all clever
company management nothing because you
need to say the test winner i
think germany is very special with the
stiftung weretest so we're
really
on the road a lot internationally and that's germany  It is very
unique
that of course if you win at
Stiftung Warentest the enormous booster is
because it simply creates trust, but
I think what you always have to know
and be clear about is that you are an enormous booster
because the 1st test win is
an enormous booster but you
don’t have it  You didn't
book it, so I think it's extremely important
that you use it, but at the same time
you know that you can't
be dependent and that's why it's
so important that we continue to invest in it in our
marketing channels that
we can, even if it  of course what does
it cost but also in vienna
tv eg really broad make the brand known of course
so tv is easy  oh a
broad medium that
simply increases brand awareness and so we watch tv
and we know how our brand
awareness is increasing over time
meanwhile we are because you can already tell
at 62% brand awareness and in the
respective country the 120 percent exactly 20
percent then really emma and
i think that's very important to understand
so a test winner seal is correct
the difference between 20 percent
growth and 60 percent growth yes i think
in that year that's what we
had it was in with colleagues is when
we when the test i came out  it was of
course an enormous factor in germany for
the growth as a result but again that
’s just germany so
germany is one of our biggest
markets that’s right but it’s also
not the only big
market cooked very differently
yes yes yes there are big differences there
are countries  they want to sleep much, much
softer script countries that want to sleep much more
firmly es g  there are countries that
actually want to buy beds,
so scandinavia is the box spring bed market, so to speak,
they don’t know the
concept of the mattress in the classic
sense, i.e. of needles, there are big
differences on the
corresponding places for our purchase, so
the many want to try it out, some of
us  not coal at all so you see
if you look at the statistics
like that in the uk more than every second
mattress is bought online and
if you are in southern europe southern europe crux in
detail i don't know exactly where it
is but presumably less than 10
percent is supposed to be there  what is sold online
so from there the markets are in
different stages but i
think that you can of course
see the trend everywhere that more and
more people are buying online
nonetheless
we believe that the trade
will continue to exist of course
it faces a challenge  the
switch to the online channel but trade
via  it will continue to exist
i firmly believe in it and that's why
we fall back on this strategy also
returns from a point of view a
mattress is already the super product
cultures since i definitely better than
fashion
that that's right but
nevertheless it's also a
challenge even if under 10  Of course
you have to think about what you do with the mattresses when they come back,
so I mean alone for
environmental reasons I mean that they
only had languages that is a very large produ
t and so what we have
tarted now is when sma second life
hat we process the mattr
sses  and as new products also
reunite again which are rationed after a few
days for exactly that does the
customer exactly say within ten
days it doesn't suit me after
one night say how do I think that I
didn't order my size or the wrong
size yes but stupidly  was already
unpacked and before you
see it  That's the way products are
checked by us, so to speak,
which ones are suitable, but
we process that that's
one of those things that we just
want to push because even if there are
low quotas, it's otherwise important that
it somehow works sustainably. In
general, it's interesting if
at first glance he thinks that excellence
in execution means super military
processes and being totally
precise and controlling everything and
somehow everything precisely so that you have managed
this excellently that's how i would
have imagined what you can do with
startups that are then strong in execution
always so also
granted now you explain a
bit actually my big tournament
in the podcast execution being strong
now somehow means, above all, transferring a
lot of responsibility to the
employees don’t even go into the
processes themselves but let the people
do it this compulsion to the  farmers
to give the budgets no budg  to
give but only to say still makes
the best of it so in the sense of if
it makes sense to invest half a
million somewhere then the
person should from where I do so the logic here
is always maybe
to understand if someone half
million am going out and it makes sense
then the person maybe writes an e-mail to
a few people
around well that's but that's
what we expect even then that you
send an e-mail after a
decision the decision has already been
made and  inform simple people
and then
if necessary you still have 24 hours,
so to speak, but i don't find the idea
that intelligent at all i have
another point that i would like to bring
up but
don't expect an open ball but
just get started and that's it  have
discussed before, yes, mistakes can
happen, but the mistakes are less
like losing entrepreneurship
foul eleven u  And the other part,
as you mentioned, you give the
people 100 percent responsibility,
I think what is enormously
important, however, is that the right people
only come from other countries, and if we do support them in the
meantime, what we will
discuss with them again is you
have to get yourselves together  think about how he recruits
if someone doesn't do it for me so well
you might have been doing online marketing
for ten years but
just can't think innovatively and further
so when
we recruit we look at topics like companies
someone like me puts it casually,
so to speak  smart in the classic way his
logical thinking is someone how can he
how does he roll up his sleeves so
is someone who can be precise and how
how does he work in collaboration with
other people so to speak
we call it people leadership those are
the dimensions of the bands  look
they have nothing to do with experience should drive
this personality because we
believe  en because
the entrepreneurs have the right talents people who
can and want to create process excellence it almost doesn’t matter
what they did before they’ll
get it done he didn’t say
why did you me that sounds like
the growing company is profitable
top team why did you give up the
majority if it hadn't also given up a few
percent i can understand that
sometimes you want to take something off the table
probably
have to want to have security and if you want to give up but why
give more he's was just a
discussion we had back then  we had how we
structure the whole thing and in the end
it's give and take I think that
's why and that's okay
we structured it in such a way that you're both
trading and convinced that
we should continue to do it in the
lobby like  we do it and that's
why we have the freedom
and yes this dna we have a part
l of the deal was always clear to us
emma's dna won't
change if we were like that
otherwise we wouldn't have made such a deal he's
always a bit of
that phenomenon that you see right now
that many stars at once
is not that young here but he is of the
current last 12 years there are a
lot of stars their names are like
girls
there was the early there was a reason
for how do you get there honestly there
isn't that exciting
story that was my project  assuming we are
yes i said yes we originally had an
online shop for mattresses
and emma was then a project
on the side
i don't think any of my
company can say exactly today this project name
came about so of course there were
us competitors who did the same  so
people had yes or in
the uk so it came out that as
far as I know we used
the people name in the end
and when we then sat  agt okay now
the project is finished the country was already
now does the thing show what's the
name of the baby yes let's call it that
was also before projects
but how was everyone with
the company infected like that and that's how it
came about  it's
not that kind of one either, we analyzed the market extensively
and then
decided what would fit best
from a brand positioning point of view or
not, so
then I would have to disappoint you, but I
still did quite a lot with the logo, for example
seen him
is the time going on somehow
that was blue and then you could
read is orange exactly that apparently
not sufficient which is
strong yes whether now a color the
conversion so fast and wise
I don't know but that's because I
told friends  had that we
dealt with magic relatively late
and what we finally did now
we noticed we want the
people  en help to a better life
and life is not soporific in a lot of blue
but it is more like something
orange energizing the that's how it came
about but we
only revealed that after a few years after a few years
after we looked more closely at
each other was about it  no
idea do you think that the whole market
sees it a bit
consolidated that already i think
taken over so made with a future
nevertheless there are now yes from
that phase and in general there are
quite a lot you read but mattress
wars and so so so typical
segment or  a development you
have to think like that one day it would
consolidate like the
voucher pages or now with the
food click commerce there are
also a lot of companies and in the
end a few stay and buy
each other is the same with you  yes,
i think it has been happening
for a while now, so there were
a lot of competitors to d  at this
point in time around 2015 2016 i would say it
started that has now
separated the wheat from the chaff a bit
so you can see now in the industry
or in the countries it is really very
country-specific who is now
established and who will
continue to be there next
the interesting thing is relevant to you it's
in europe or fixed is far you have to
say worldwide it's always a
regional market so we're
already one of the most international
brands there is so we
have another competitor
core competitor in germany versus
france versus the uk  verso spain would
so i can name all the countries there is
always another core competitor that
we have there and we are germany at the
start i think that better known so bett
1 is the
big player so tame from berlin and
who somehow go together you know
each other there  if you talk but that's not an
issue yes i think he has a
strategy for u  our strategy and
not personally even never
met ok and other countries had
met at the time or soy sauce depends a
bit on the country and therefore the
competitor there are countries in the uk
or in france we have
met before but yes it is
the
european caspar operations would have
taken over very local business when they went back
i don't know that at all i think that
's why he's so diffused i think the
people want to quit and have spread
to other areas and i
had my office in berlin so if i got
that right  off in my head but then i
'm not that deep into it now and do
you still give classic brands from the
past, i.e. from 22, 30, 40 or 100
years ago that also plays a role
or are it in the nature is these new ones it
was clear to me, so to speak  the
classic brands the traditional
markets continue we said that before
i bought it once
actually we did it once  what
bought it was doping
but it doesn't exist like these online
players and nine players we'll
actually have someone different in each country
it's just as much in the traditional
area so there's actually only
one international player has was
from short put up is one
or  is, so to speak, the other
international sleep brand that still
exists besides us, they are
also active in many countries, more than
unlikely,
but otherwise it is always a local
game, always a different brand, which is
no longer to be said, now a
brand senses the use of the economies of scale
could yes i think that's
part of the topic what we were planning where
is production done you often produce locally
because it's too expensive for transport
and i think that based on this
historical
logic that conditioning
across countries might not have made
that much sense  is at least
so my
my explanation that now really the
d  he case is probably you can there
you can there so if you do a thesis
on why that helped when i know
it not only details who now an
explanation and is the endgame then for
you one day that has to be brought to the
stock market towards  I do
n't know so then sometimes so martially towards
it
really seriously cinema
is a vision you said yes first of
all the goal is that we worldwide become the
ones for a sleep mask and
we still have a bit of plans that
we're going to drill big boards  we
have to talk about it in china and the
usa so we still have plenty of topics
ahead of us but i mean
fresh capital with a bit of a stock exchange and
that was also possible
here i always have my stock exchange here so it
's a blessing i don't know exactly
So if you always have
corresponding representatives here who are also
listed on the stock exchange, I spoke to him
once and he said if the
stock market is up, you're finally  I'm a real
entrepreneur already on the way you have
to deal with all this stock market stuff and the
entertainment of the analysts
is actually not that much
fun so you have to think very carefully
about whether you want to do something like
that ok and of course there are companies
they have to do it because
they have to finance themselves, but
we have the luxurious situation that
we're running profitably and don't
need that. expansions
now in the usa and china at the same time
you can do everything from the cash flow country,
that's what we're doing right now
you can only roughly get past that
but that's what we
said before i don't think it's
so much about the capital but our
never exciting there if you
hate limited capital and can still get
the most out of it, so that's
why  enough but still has to
somehow already then when the amount of money
is the mattresses for you manufactures and of
course  I'm unclear, however, there are enough
examples, let's talk more questions for now
, I think the
ram had collected 500 million us dollars in the meantime
, that's just a
lot more from you,
and they're currently having their growth
difficulties on the us market,
so I don't think they're missing the
capital  the desire i even think that it is
a hindrance because of this dna that
we developed i discussed with manu
when we started
whether we should buy a telephone
for 60 euros or whether
a telephone for 20 euros would do the trick so
listen to it  It sounds a bit banal at first
but I would always have to
think about whether the money is well spent
because I think that makes a difference and
accordingly also in China or the USA okay
how do we proceed now without
simply burning too much money of
course we have to  we invest but
let's invest smart i think
that's the entrepreneurial
okay so i got it  it
couldn't be better but you can do it and if you
don't take on any investors now what
is of course incredibly charming when
you can develop these markets
gigantic what I mean if you
imagine the usa and china are the
market size you are entering now it
will probably come soon  over years of
turnover
we definitely still have goals let's
hope
we are always this different
data in the sense of we don't go out there
big big things but we want
to grow again in a similar corridor
in absolute numbers like
last year so last year  we've grown to 52
million so it's
demanding you have to say that
we like to set ambitious
goals is a coming we'll have to see that
means it will be the sales threshold in the next 18 24
months
if that happened
i wouldn't be sad what i think that and
this is a huge market because they have to
sleep everyone has to sleep
then and how  mentioned at the beginning is super
important and that’s why my sleep
tip also use the alarm clock to
remind yourself that you should finally go to bed that you have
a problem at
11 p.m. my alarm clock rings to tell me
because there’s still an hour to
go now  going to bed soon so will
alarm clock science centers is i
can also say if you forgot
to show it and fell asleep at 10
p.m. that sucks only
then woke up again but otherwise that’s
actually a good tip for me at least
okay kraska is so  what a
huge store and what an
opportunity again heart is that expected at the
beginning so
we thought but that was also
the problem with investors we thought
i honestly thought to sell ten million
after five years that
's a
lot  see if we can get there but we'll
count the investors but
clarity can imagine how it
works and says we'll do e.g  Eight million
euros in sales after five years and then he
thinks that's also
including VAT before cancellations and
then you achieve that
half of the EU and pipapo country ends up spending 4 2
million realistic sales because
nobody gives money for
and yes that  was the cursed blessing at
the time so in the sense of back then it was
a bit of a curse we thought it
can't be that we don't get any money
and today we know that
made us stronger there are
also mantras in the city world doesn't matter
what you do ensures that you have
as big a tam as possible, so they are
famous aunt travel market,
then everything will be fine
and in the end I also explained a
bit of success in this segment so
the tam is just huge because it's
when we  a product that everyone needs, of course
, maybe water or a
vaccine or something, but there are not
many and baywa taste is just like that and
probably the tip
basically good that you
should choose in topics notices so
should be
as big as possible I think because
you shouldn't imagine that you can
realistically have 80
percent of the market share in a small market
from there that helps if it's big I
don't think so  that's i think
that's not that not that in the end the
question is whether you're successful or not
i really think it's about in the end and
execution video his company paus what we have
today you how you work on it whether the
smart makes business decisions
okay okay then  well i think he
can now imagine more and more
than before is more but still
has become for me and the happy
there it needs in advance have
just another colleague
always someone always ordered so if
on the way you're straight in  i
drove past a parcel
delivery man to deal with the wife emma's mattress
so it's always on top of the mountain so that was
for  for a while then yes, I
mean if we send such a large box
it also makes sense
to write logos on it but have you
optimized it so not that where I want to
look then we have
optimized the box it really works to
tackle a little letter  but
otherwise it's not that's
not performance-optimized so
according to the motto we have to print the logo
everything's fine so if
you want to sleep smart in the near future and want to set an
alarm clock maybe because
you're so happy you can or will do that
would like to work can get in touch because it's
always nice to see
talented people here entrepreneurs already
people exactly otherwise first of
all thank you two come yes thank you everything made clear
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr